We're here with the beautiful inside and out
Vanessa Hudgens.
(applause)
Okay.
Girl talk.
Yes.
So the last time you came on the show,
you gave me some dating advice.
Hmm hmm.
I was, you know, I'm single,
I'm still single.
And,
and I like being single,
so I'm not very like eager and active.
Yeah.
That's like my best friend.
It's like kids, work,
friends.
Yeah.
Alone.
You're full
Alone time is a huge priority for me.
Yeah.
And then it's fifth.
That's why Gayle King is like,
'you're, like, that's why you're single
because it's your fifth priority.'
But
you told me
that if I did notice someone
that maybe
I should slip into their DMs.
It's the thing, everybody does it.
So
I really,
I know that slipping into the DMs
is the term
and I, I honestly like, because you motivated me,
I figured out even how to do it.
A huh.
So I DM'd a guy.
Okay.
Hot.
Love that.
Thank you for.
Of course.
Giving me advice.
Well, I mean, you're Drew Barrymore.
Any man would be lucky.
(applause)
Thank you.
Well, thank you for saying that.
Now
you were just in Rihanna's
Savage X Fenty show,
Yeah.
And you look,
holy cow.
That's art.
That's me.
The herringbone, wishbone tail,
(applause)
the body, the cross-straps, the lighting.
I felt like I was probably swinging my arms too much.
That's what I took away from that photo.
But, other than that, I was so excited.
I had always, like grown up watching,
like the Victoria Secret runway shows, you know?
And I was like, 'Ooh, that's so cool.
And empowering. And they just look so fierce.
Like, I would love to do that one day',
but then again, I'm 5'3"
so that was never going to happen to me.
And then Rihanna asked if I would be in her show
and I was just like
a, of course she's an icon,
but b, like, what she stands for is so inclusive.
She celebrates women of all shapes and sizes and colors.
And to be a part of that is just so, it's dope.
It's an honor.
That was just so hot.
And you can see the Savage X Fenty show on Amazon Prime
every year that it comes out.
It is like a knockout hit.
People love it.
I love it.
I'm so excited to watch it.
Well, it's a show.
Yeah,
It's not.
It's a production.
It's insane.
It's like a carnival, a festival.
It's art.
It is.
Well, speaking of
that's a perfect parlay into Halloween,
which is I hear it's your favorite holiday?
And I heard it's your holiday.
(laughter)
It's my favorite holiday
in the world.
Watch us turn into five-year-olds.
I know!
But it's true
because it's the holiday with no baggage.
Yeah!
Gosh forbid you don't have to get presents.
You can be the freak you are.
You can be
with whoever you want to be with.
Now,
You have had some really incredible costumes over the years.
Can we take a look at just a few?
Sure!
All right, here we go.
Black Widow.
(gasps)
I know. It's amazing.
See that's what I love. Full tilt commitment.
Yeah.
All right. And next we have Catwoman,
saw it on the monitor.
Oh my gosh!
And than we can't forget about Darla.
Cause she's the Batgirl.
(laugher)
You can be her too!
(applause)
Like I want to be!
Do it!
I'll send you the link.
I'm going to put on that outfit
and DM somebody.
I'm just going to say
'do as Vanessa does'!
I actually had my first FaceTime with my boyfriend
while I was in a Spider Woman costume
because me and my best friend
were filming a thing.
And we had our Spider Woman costumes
that she had made for us.
We're fanatics about Halloween and dressing up.
And I was texting him and I was like,
'I'm in this really cute fit right now.
I feel like we should maybe have our first FaceTime.'
I think he's pretty happy about it.
It was great. It was a great moment.
Very memorable.
How is he by the way?
He's great!
He's adorable.
Yeah.
He's like a foot taller than me.
It's great.
Oh.
Look at that!
He took me to a sunflower field
cause he knows I love sunflowers.
It's nice to be with a guy who actually listens
and is very kind.
And you're so deserving of that.
Thank you.
You really are.
So are you.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Well, again, fifth priority
because my number one priority is my kids.
And I can tell you what we're going to be doing.
We're going to be watching your new Netflix movie
called 'My Little Pony, a New Generation'.
Yes.
I cannot wait for this.
Tell me about it.
What are we in store for?
I'm so excited about it
because I mean, end of the day,
like My Little Pony has been around
for like almost 40 years.
And like the legacy is all about friendship and,
and spreading love and joy.
And this movie really sticks to that theme,
but it is the new generation.
And I feel like it's very reflective
of where we are in society.
The unicorns, the Pegasi,
and the earth ponies have been all separated.
They don't know each other.
They have these preconceived ideas of each other
and it's really driven by,
by fear.
But it's about that.
It's about finding your own sparkle,
celebrating the things that make you unique.
The messages are so strong and powerful,
but like just wonderfully bite-size for children
to take in.
All right. Well, we have a clip.
Let's take a look.
(sniffing)
What are you doing?
You don't smell.
Thanks.
Wait, what?
I was told all you earth ponies smell
like rotten sardines,
but you do not.
Hmm.
What else do unicorn say about earth ponies?
Oh,
just that you're lazy
and not the brightest crystals in
the forest.
Charming.
Nope,
just those three.
(applause)
Wow.
Vanessa,
thank you.
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
Always the best seeing know.
It's always the best seeing you
do as Vanessa does.
I cannot wait to watch you in the
Savage X Fenty show
on Amazon Prime.
I cannot wait to watch you and the Netflix,
'My Little Pony: a New Generation'
with the girls
and I just
I've loved you then,
I love you now.
I love you forever.
Vanessa Hudgens!
(applause)
(upbeat music)